hey guys how's it going so what you want
to do is you want to buy and sell a
three dose of a potion and then you want
to buy a four dose of the potion so you
can check the prices for it so this
stuff here is how you check the margins
of the potions so whatever price you
bought the dose 41 at you times that by
75 and that converts it to a price in a
dose three so
3214 and then you take that by
whatever price you sold your dose 31 out
and that equals
231 and that's how much profit You' be
making per potion okay so we know the
prices for the three dose so just go
ahead and buy some three do of the
potion and I'll try um about 2,000 of
them so
3058 that's good bort and they insta
bort which is good and then you use this
guy here who changes all your three dose
to four dose potions and then you can
sell them right back and then we know
the price here which is um
4285 so we sell them for
434 and then if you look at the history
we bought it for 6 million 94 GP and uh
we're going to sell it for 644 so that's
about a over 300K profit and it didn't
take very long so that's pretty good so
all these potions have sold now so yeah
it's about 300K and it took about 3
minutes in total to do this which is
pretty good and um with this sell price
here you normally just like buy for one
GP more than what you sold it for but
since the buy and the sell price is so
close together you can just um instantly
buy them all so it's really
quick and these potions here are the
best ones to try this for and it's a
really good money-making method because
some people don't know you can change
the dose from 3 to 4 noted and also it's
a bit more difficult to check the
margins for it so you can actually make
a lot of profit by doing this method so
yeah um thanks for watching